we've talked about this yesterday we
talked about one of the williams sisters
now there will be no williams sisters
playing at the u.s open next week listen
i'm gonna miss the open it's my favorite
slam i've had so many amazing memories
there and i can't wait to get back out
on the court whenever that is i'll work
with my team to make it as soon as i can
uh
venus venus venus we're going to miss
you i know venus said yesterday that
she's withdrawing from the grand slam
tennis classic due to a leg injury she
made the announcement of course after
her sister serena revealed on instagram
that a torn hamstring will keep her out
of the action so now we've got roger
federer you mentioned this yesterday
anthony roger federer rafael nadal they
announced that they will also miss the
tournament also due to injuries the us
open which starts on monday will be the
first grand slam event without the
williams sisters federer or nadal since
1997. and that's yeah we're starting
without venus and serena since 2003
there's still going to be a lot of good
tennis yes but those are certainly some
of the biggest names in the business and
remember in 1997 that is where venus
sort of made a break for it she came in
unseated yeah and destroyed everybody
and
you know history was written um we want
them to get healthy yes as we said
yesterday it's all about you guys
i feel good it is